let's get to the judicial reform ever
since this digital reform was proposed
back in January this country has been in
a state of turmoil you pause this
legislation in order to allow for talks
with the opposition because you were
worried like many people in the country
besides fighting for each other could
descend into a civil war but those talks
with the opposition now of broken down
and you say you may Advance this
legislation unilaterally are you not
willing to return to the talks with the
opposition at all will you just continue
now to unilaterally pass this
legislation well I definitely sought a
broad consensus possibly in a formal
agreement with the opposition but what
we discovered after I pushed the pause
button after one month and two months
and three months that the opposition was
under such political pressures that they
couldn't agree to the most minimal
understanding they couldn't agree to
things that we brought up
by the opposition leaders before they
went into opposition can you be more
specific though what will you change
from the original proposal from this
measured proposal what will be different
well I already changed a few things
right after the original proposal was
put forward I said that the idea of a of
an override Clause where the the
parliament the knesset can override the
decisions of the Supreme Court with a
simple majority I said I threw that up
if that's not coming back at all you're
not following this and people don't know
they just don't follow well we thought
it might come back with the super
majority no I said it's it's out okay
and I and I think we it's very clear
that the way of choosing judges is not
going to be the the it's not going to be
the current structure but it's not going
to be the original structure let's talk
about Iran's relationship with Russia
Iran is now supplying Russia with drones
that it uses in Ukraine and Russia has a
deal with Iran to supply it with fighter
jets combat helicopters the Russia is
helping Iran Advance its cyber
capabilities potentially its missile
production facilities how does this new
relationship between Iran and Russia
change the relationship between Israel
and Russia well it's a very disturbing
relationship obviously partnership
because it it gives Iran the weapons of
the means to uh Advance its goals
against Israel and others against the
Arab states and against many others uh
and it also Iran is supplying Russia
with the weapons that are used to uh in
in the war of Ukraine with deadly effect
uh so obviously we're concerned with
that we've made our concerns known to
the Russians uh we are also helping
Ukraine we're helping them uh in
civilian defense and alert civilian
alert system that prevents that will
obviate the need to get half the country
in shelters for every missile fired so
we're helping them with that but we're
making our concerns to uh the Russian
government what did Moscow say back can
you can you share that with us well I
think they're aware of our concerns and
I think that
I think it's important to understand
that we're concerned also with the
possibility
that systems that we would give to
Ukraine would fall in fall into Iranian
hands and could be reverse engineered uh
and we would find ourselves facing
Israeli systems used against Israel and
by the way that's not a theoretical
system a theoretical threat because
Western system anti-tank systems for
example uh did exactly that journey and
we now find them uh on our borders with
Hezbollah remember Israel is a country
the size of New Jersey it's been pelted
with twenty thousand more than twenty
thousand Rockets okay and in a very uh
dense densely populated country we
haven't had many casualties for one
reason because Iron Dome shoots down 95
percent of the missiles that enter our
uh could it could hit our populated
centers now if that system were to fall
in the hands of Iran then the millions
of Israelis would be left defenseless
and imperiled are you aware of what the
Ukrainian Ambassador Israel said
recently that uh Israel says its dance
is neutral about this conflict between
Ukraine and Russia but he said in
reality it's pro-russia he said that
Israel really hadn't delivered on his
promises regarding Aid to Ukraine how'd
he respond to those decisions by the
Ukrainian ambassadors well that's not
true the former government made some
promises which were in the process well
they weren't deliberate but I've
delivered them and I think people know
maybe should
find out what's going on but we're not
neutral we've expressed our sympathy and
our position with Ukraine but I'm saying
there is a limit limitations that we
have and concerns and interests that we
have and my first interest uh regardless
of sympathy and the steps that we take
is to ensure the security of the one and
only Jewish State and we have uh the
concerns that I told you we are also
our Pilots are flying right next to
Russian pilots in over the Skies of
Syria in order to block the attempts of
Iran to establish a second Hezbollah
front in Syria is there any indication
that the Iranians are trying to build a
nuclear bomb itself a nuclear warhead
well there is more than indication
because I sent the Mossad to the heart
of Tehran and they brought back Iran's
secret nuclear archive and the opening
document of that archive said that
Iran's purpose
20 years ago 21 years ago in 2003 was to
build five kiloton bombs that's five
Hiroshima bombs that's 21 years ago so
you can assume that they haven't
abandoned the school but is there
evidence that they're Reviving that
project well they certainly have revived
that project in the sense that they're
moving all the time with enrichment as
you said which is a critical component
of making a nuclear bomb it's not the
only component there's also the weapon
weaponization group there's also the
missile group can you tell us what's
happening with the webinarization group
I could but I won't the US is now
re-engaging diplomatically with Iran
quote a mini deal around its nuclear
program do you think this so-called mini
deal is the first stage in Reviving The
Old Iran deal or do you think the older
and deal is really dead
any deal with Iran that doesn't set back
their nuclear infrastructure that
doesn't uh basically take it apart is
not very useful how many just said well
I'm willing to enter a deal I just will
not roll back any of the infrastructure
you said that about the mini deal and he
wants to get money he's going to get
billions so I think that's a bad deal
obviously a deal which would give them
hundreds of billions of dollars and
would enable them within two years three
years in what is called the sunset
Clause to remove all limitations on the
nuclear enrichment is a far worse deal
so look maximum deal or many deal
nothing neither is going to stop us from
doing what we need to do to defend
Israel against a regime that openly says
it's out to destroy us and is seeking to
achieve the means to do so so we will do
whatever is necessary to defend
ourselves you've known President Biden
now for over four decades your friendly
relationship since the establishment of
the new government you haven't received
an invitation to the White House some of
your senior ministers can't get meetings
with the body Administration as well
what does that say about the current
nature of the relationship between
Israel and the United States well you're
quite right I've known uh President
Biden for over 40 years and it's been a
close friendship we don't we don't
always agree we often disagree but it's
instructive to I think he's a
self-described Zionist pro-israel and I
don't think that's an inaccurate
description I think it's accurate I
think he has a basic Sympathy for the
Jewish State although as in any family
we can disagree and often do but I have
no doubt about his sentiment and and I
trust that that will continue and I can
also tell you that in the times of the
Obama administration when Mr Biden was
vice president he often served as a
channel to try to
find
I would say a middle ground during times
of intense conflict so the Friendship is
not a question now here's what people
don't know I mean this issue of the
invitation clouds people's uh
views and actually their knowledge of
what is happening with our two
governments and in fact the security
cooperation the military cooperation and
the Intel cooperation including cyber is
stronger than it's ever been under our
two governments I've spoken to the
president in a few a few weeks ago on on
the phone since then I may not go to
Washington but Washington is coming here
with a steady flow including the
National Security advisor Jake Sullivan
and secretary blinken and the chief of
the CIA all of whom I've met of course
and the phone calls that are regular the
last 15 months have been the most
violent period in the West Bank in over
two decades you know the reason the coin
too is really officials is because the
Palestinian Authority has lost control
over some areas what is your solution
for this is it as some people say some
people in your government say to put
more Israeli Security Services in those
areas or is it to strengthen the
Palestine Authority there that's both
but they failed the second has failed I
mean they failed they're stuck in their
own
convoluted politics which is undergoing
some convulsion but I think I think
you're quite right I mean northern
Samaria has become sort of a No Man's
landed which you have more and more
terror attacks that emanate from there
and my policy has been to
um
definitely to keep the Palestinian
Authority I don't want it to dissolve
the way people are talking it's simply
ridiculous